democrats are in deep trouble and
expected to get wiped out in the
midterms so guess who they're turning to
for help god kamala harris
the underprepared vp who's embarrassed
herself pretty much everywhere all over
the world she's gonna be hitting the
road to tell you ready the president's
successes
democrat strategists also funny democrat
strategists calling her one of the most
effective voices now that is funny that
that's some great script right there
it's a sick judge
drop that one out again you think that
woman is a road warrior to discuss and
rescue the dems are you stupid i mean
this woman is one of the most
ineffective voices i've ever heard and
the the amazing part of it and by the
way i'm all for it send her out send her
to everybody
every train station get that woman out
there and they say we want to give her a
more typical schedule because of colvin
she couldn't go out and the crowds
couldn't come out the crowds won't come
out anyway just put her on zoom let her
talk let her laugh she knows nothing so
i
mean
i'm with the judge this is a good idea
we need her in every swing state we need
her on television this is good
her husband got covered and she didn't
because even covet doesn't want to have
anything to do oh
wow that's harsh
this is just too comical
the judge was talking about the crowds
she spoke to her biggest crowd yet of
140 people
and then they blamed kovitz saying we
need to keep the crowds intentionally
sparse she can't even control her
cackling and caterwaulin as a woman who
tends to be shrill that is like the
first thing that you need to work on in
in your public persona and at this state
in this day and age you can't even get
that underground nine people who work
for her and nowhere quit how bad are
things where kamala
is your best messenger yeah there's a
couple of problems one she is losing
staffers faster than russia's losing
generals
she is supposed to sell success okay
here's the issue you have a message in a
messenger sometimes you don't have two
positives like you could have a really
great message and a terrible messenger
or a great messenger and a bad message
the problem is bad message bad messenger
what success can she tout afghanistan
inflation the border mass mandates the
crime wave if that's success what are
their failures having her self-success
is like me selling big and tall suits
it's amazing but i mean she says that's
that thing and also she's when she's in
public she's bad so you have to assume
well maybe privately she's personable
no
they must not like her so she's
on on stage terrible and in private
obnoxious she's a lot like me
i love her
you notice we're the only greens at the
table yeah and i'm not irish and neither
are you okay but they said it's a toxic
place she's got it's your turn did you
go yet
i didn't do that no i did go go i you
did go i did go oh get a room
i want to say this about kamala harris
she's not
she didn't come out she wasn't created
out of uh you know out of heaven or
whole cloth she was an attorney general
the
the largest state in the country
a a crime fighting district attorney
united states senator uh and then uh
vice president she's not nothing i mean
she's a very uh pivotal historic
character she goes to howard university
where she graduate for example and it's
like jesus returning i mean
i think that in this in this toxic
partisan world let me think about it
jesus christ in this
in this toxic environment at this table
she is you know we can see it's easy to
to throw these pejoratives at the vice
president united states but she is well
regarded
democrat women didn't support them give
her a chance i give her a chance she
just told us
what the hell is
i think you're in the highest position
in the united states
she's an embarrassment to every young
girl who looks to her i think
bars while she was smoking pot but a lot
of people did that at that time i didn't
i
she tried to prosecute parents for their
children's truancy in schools she she
was well regarded by republicans in that
job because they thought she was tough
on crime oh because she was close now
the world changed or although you did
your best
very good fight and we're very proud of
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else